Stephen Strange the illuminati will see you now
we will see what kind of doctor strange you are
Welcome back everyone this would be my brand new
doctor strange multiverse of madness x-men video
also break down the cinemacon footage that
they showed off yesterday when kevin feige
also announced that they're planning the
next 10 years of marvel movies right now
that's right the next 10 years of your
life are being mapped out that's like
a whole other saga after the infinity
saga like secret war saga mild shock
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs here
everybody is playing the x-men theme song in their
head while they're watching this so if you're
brand new to the channel we're doing a giveaway
for imax tickets all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just leave your favorite
moment from the trailers on the video the movie's
coming out next week so all my really big easter
egg videos for the entire movie my post credit
scene videos will start posting after the movie
comes out my review video with no spoilers will
post on tuesday when we're allowed to post that
but starting with the big stuff first here
there's new footage of professor x in his x-men
the animated series looking yellow floaty chair it
doesn't mean he's the same professor x from that
animated universe even though everybody's thinking
that in their head like oh my god it's just like
the animated series it's just meant to be a sly
wink at that because these are all multiverse
variants of versions from a bunch of big deep
cuts from the comics and from the marvel movies
in the case of captain carter a big deep cut
for the what if series don't worry i'll explain
her too because we also get new footage with
captain carter this version of patrick stewart's
professor x is meant to be from a different
live-action universe where things are similar
to what's happening in the x-men the animated
series universe like they all use the classic
costumes from the comics like i love using the
clips of wolverine like there's wolverine versus
thanos during infinity war with him just getting
snapped over and over again there's also the
deleted scene from the wolverine movie where he
gets his comic book accurate yellow in black suit
you have to imagine in this alternate universe
where this version of professor x comes from
he wears a costume that looks like that the
way the hugh jackman explained the wolverine
costume that he wore in all the different x-men
movies that he starred in the fox marvel movies
is that originally when brian singer did those
x-men movies he and a lot of the fox people were
dead set against actually doing things exactly
like the comics making them all wear the comic
book accurate costumes they even have a line in
that first x-men movie where they make fun of
the classic costumes you actually go outside in
these things what would you prefer yellow spandex
jackman even said that brian singer banned comics
on the set of that movie and kevin feige had to go
like sneak comics around to a bunch of different
people to give them insight into their characters
it was until he was hired to be president
of marvel studios later that people actually
started listening to him but if you wonder why you
never actually saw a wolverine in any of those fox
marvel movies wearing a costume like that like
you saw in the deleted scene is because the
people that controlled those movies didn't want
to put him in it when this version of professor
x in the trailer says let's see what kind of
doctor strange you are to rmcu doctor strange
that just means the illuminati are wary about the
evil doctor strange variants like sinister strange
or like doctor strange supreme from the what if
series versions that go off the rails and become
crazy powerful and become this huge threat to the
multiverse they don't know anything about rmcu
doctor strange yet so they're just treating him in
a very cautious way they are actually making new
episodes of the real x-men the animated series
it's called x-men 97. i've done a couple videos
about it before the episodes will pick up after
the ending of the original x-men animated series
episodes that you remember watching way back in
the 90s so it'll be like them just continuing
the story after a really really long hiatus
those will be coming to disney plus next year
in fun fact one of the reasons why they did x-men
2000 back in the day was because of the popularity
of the animated series that's why they were viewed
as being more commercially viable than some of the
other marvel characters that they had access to
at the time there's brand new footage of captain
carter like i said played by haley atwell if that
wasn't clear she is captain carter so it's live
action hayley atwell coming back from avengers end
game to do this but she also came back to play the
version during what if as well so technically
she has already come back to the mcu in a way
her captain america shield is painted to look
exactly like the one from what if with the british
flag instead of the american flag her costume
looks like the captain britain costume because
she is a british version of captain america but
in the comics brian braddock the actual captain
britain has a very different magical king arthur
style origin story which sort of ties in with what
happened in the eternals movie in camelot and the
black knight character so we'll see if we see an
mcu version of captain britain at some point
they already mentioned him during avengers end
game they mentioned an agent braddock so there is
a captain britain somewhere in the timeline of the
mcu somewhere she's a jet pack device on her back
and she's fighting a version of the scarlet witch
variant who's basically just mowing through all
the multiverse illuminati destroying every little
piece of their base here as possible but if it
weren't clear this version of captain carter
is not the exact same version from the what if
series the producers explained why so many of the
characters are based on the what-if characters but
not meant to be the exact same what-if characters
there's also a bunch of brand new footage of this
captain marvel variant which is very hd very crisp
and clearly looks like maria rambeau from another
universe it's not their iron man variant even
though a variant of iron man would be working with
them i've done a couple iron man videos recently
that's talking about like a completely different
character i think a lot of people just see iron
man on videos and they think people are talking
about this the illuminati's version of iron man
would be the person who was responsible for the
iron legion the ultron looking robots because
that's obviously where they came from during
avengers age of ultron the maria rambeau captain
marvel variant is just from a universe where on
the day the captain marvel got her powers she was
a test pilot flying the tesseract ship and that's
when she got into the accident and became captain
marvel it just happened to be maria rambeau that
day because she's a test pilot just like carol
danvers was the reason why they're doing this
maria rambeau captain marvel variant is because
it's a deep cut from the actual marvel comics
because originally monica rambeau called herself
captain marvel long before like many years before
carol danvers ever called herself captain marvel
so they're just winking at that version even
though it's maria rambeau instead of actual
monica rambeau then there's a new scene of
mcu scarlet witch destroying all the skeletal
aspects of the marvel zombies version of defender
strange later in the movie at the darkhold temple
looking all pissed off in doing it just as quickly
as thanos got rid of all doctor strange's copies
when he was doing the same spell during avengers
infinity war just splitting himself into all those
different aspects then in the clip they have this
big attack with gargantos doctor strange going
to rescue america chavez and her explaining
the multiverse to him earlier in the movie
the nightmares that he's having are actually the
scenes that you see defender strange and america
chavez running from this big creature that's being
controlled by scarlet witch with the chaos magic
in the runes they try to escape through this space
where they're keeping the book of the vashanti
and then he basically looks at her like look kid
you gotta escape but while that's happening rmcu
doctor strange thinks that it's just a dream that
he's having and it's not real he doesn't know
that it's actually real he winds up going to mcu
christine palmer's wedding which is happening at
the beginning of the movie and during the wedding
that's when gargantos attacks so like you see all
the people in the wedding rushing outside to the
chaos in the street just seeing what's going on
and as you see during the clip gargantos is
invisible but he's destroying the bus trying
to get america chavez who's inside of it i've
actually been able to confirm that the number
on top of the bus is a reference to the comic
book version of infinity war which is obviously
different from the movie version but it's just
another callback to infinity war now like i said
he does look more like a version of schumacher
but because that belongs to the conan ip and
marvel doesn't have rights to that right now
they can't use the schumacher name so they're
just calling him gargantos if this really were she
mcgrath he wouldn't be able to kill him that fast
he's like this god tier being he's a big cosmic
level character from between dimensions this is
where we get into the cinemacon footage they just
had like a tiny bit extra that kind of explains
her arc during the movie and what's happening with
some of these other doctor strange variants so the
way they said they're using her in the movie is
that america chavez basically explains that she is
from the multiverse she was born in the universe
the defender strange came from like that's her
original universe she knew that version of doctor
strange she doesn't totally understand how to use
her powers yet but she can punch holes through
different universes in different dimensions
our doctor strange says that he had a dream about
her in another version of doctor strange earlier
in the movie and she says no no no that actually
did happen dreams are supposed to be windows to
alternate universes in that that version of
defender strange was actually getting ready
to sacrifice her for the good of his universe
until there was a change of heart at the end
then right after she tells doctor strange dreams
of the windows to alternate universes the stuff
that you saw actually happen we actually see mcu
scarlet witch in a version of west view with a
version of billy and tommy and it's this scene
with her in the black but then we see her wake
up it was just a dream but because of what we just
saw happen with america chavez we know that she
was actually witnessing the events of an alternate
universe seeing a real version of billy and tommy
but remember her body is stuck in the mcu so
she was just seeing across universes she wasn't
literally traveling across universes yet america
chavez explains that someone is trying to capture
her and force her to open portals to alternate
universes so obviously that's the connection to
why mcu scarlet wish is doing this but if you
spotted any other big easter eggs in the new
footage that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments like i
said my non-spoilery review will probably post
tuesday morning make sure you enable alerts for
that so you don't miss that i'll name a giveaway
winner in my next big video too i'll post my full
breakdowns easter eggs everything from the movie
post credit scene videos later in the week after
it actually comes out in theaters make sure you
go see this movie as soon as possible because it
looks like it is going to be crazy in the best
possible way everyone click here for my full
Moon Knight episode 5 video in easter eggs and click
here for my doctor strange 2 living tribunal video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!